the browns aren't done yet and they've
retooled they've revamped they're hoping
to get more to odo beckham jr and they
need to get more out of their
quarterback baker mayfield he's the
subject of this segment and when i saw
his name on the rundown for today i
thought surely chris didn't drop him all
the way to number 33
on the chris sims top 40 quarterback
list and let's just be clear on that
before people in cleveland lose their
minds this is not a setup for the
graphic of the roger goodell evil twin
brother chris sims and number 33 baker
mayfield no number 33 is coming up later
this hour it's not baker mayfield baker
mayfield's in the news because he met
with the media for the first time this
entire offseason he's been quiet he has
chosen that approach he has chosen to
zip it to say less remember last year he
had a couple of interviews he did that
created some some noise and some
controversy took shots at daniel jones
if you recall that in a gq interview he
explained his new approach yesterday
when he met with reporters via video
conference as to why he has chosen to
say less not more in 2020 here's some
baker mayfield
just time to work it's time to do our
thing instead of talking about it so
this is the first immediate thing i've
done um just because
there's no need to be talking about it
it's just time to go do it uh and right
now it's you know kind of moving in
silence which is fine with me uh
that's how i
used to do it before getting on a bigger
stage so i'm happy to get back to those
routes
like i said earlier get back to the
fundamentals to where i can accomplish
the goals when the season comes around
moving in silence i like that phrase
reminds me the old cars song moving in
stereo that's before your time chris do
you like the idea that baker mayfield is
now moving in silence as opposed to
saying a lot of things that he
ultimately has to possibly explain away
or otherwise put back in context
i i do i think it's the right approach
you know i you know for a guy that's
coming off a year that was a little all
over the place yeah let's get back to
the drawing board talk is cheap you know
it's about results the league he knows
that that's why i mean this is why it's
it's really easy to root for the
cleveland browns and i find it very easy
to root for odell beckham jr and baker
mayfield and jarvis landry now there
hasn't been a lot of talk out of that
team at all this year you know really
and i think baker mayfield he was
probably a little humbled by what the
way he played last year the attention
the fact that they didn't deliver all of
those things but man i mean listen we
showed john dorsey here to start the
segment john dorsey hey one of the
reasons we're sitting here talking about
cleveland is still because of him he put
together a team that's got a lot of
talent and they did a good job this
offseason adding to that talent and
making it a more complete team so i
don't want to take any way anything away
from some of those guys there and drew
barry and people like that but i am
excited about you know baker mayfield
and the cleveland browns this year you
know first off i think he's in a lot of
ways as a leader as a quarterback he's
wise and mature beyond his years and i
think that's why they drafted him a
number one listen did he spout off to
the media every now and then would i
rather not see him do that yeah okay but
i do think this is a guy that's ultra
competitive loves the sport and tries to
hold himself to a high standard too and
he is young and he's made a few mistakes
here and there but nothing to wear i
think it's glaring or egregious
i can't reconcile your statement that
he's wise and mature beyond his years
when he does have these periodic flashes
of coming off as a spoiled brat like he
did last year with tony grossi when he
did the walk-off because he didn't like
a question that tony grossi had asked
him and there have been other occasions
where we've seen that we've seen that
competitive nature
emerge as
just the kind of behavior we don't want
and
we find ourselves i think making excuses
for him because we think he's got the
potential to be a great quarterback we
like the fire but but there are times
when he can be a jerk and i'm never a
big fan of making excuses for people who
from time to time act like jerks
although i from time to time act like a
jerk and sometimes people have to make
excuses for me for that i still don't
like having to do that i like grown men
and women to be responsible for their
own words and deeds and i think at times
he does need to mature so i don't know
that he is mature beyond his his years i
think he needs to mature i think he
needs some of his personality to catch
up with
where he is as a quarterback from the
standpoint of he gets it on the field he
needs to get it completely off the field
and what he's done this year choosing to
stay away from talking it may be a bit
of an extreme reaction but it shows
signs of maturity and growth so i think
there's something encouraging to that
well yeah and you know what i'm talking
about mature wise i'm talking about the
way he leads the way he
holds himself to a standard you know i
was there at training camp last year he
was supposed to do an interview with me
he didn't have a great practice and they
said it's very they were they were
worried as soon as practice was over
they were going oh i i hope baker will
still do the interview with you because
when he has practices like this usually
he's kind of pissed off and he goes back
in and watches more film and kind of
critiques himself and shuts the world
out and that's what he did to me i like
that you know is he a little hot-headed
and emotional and afraid to or not
afraid to speak his mind you know that
to me is what he has done within the
media sometimes i don't think it's
immaturity and obviously there was a
little issue there with tony grossi and
whatever it may be
but hey there was a lot of high
expectations for that team last year
yeah it wasn't perfect he didn't handle
every situation the right way but i
don't come away going oh man baker
mayfield's way over in a way you know in
way over his head or anything like that
i i look at a guy who's highly
competitive he wears his heart on his
sleeve in a lot of ways he does have big
talent and when he talks i listen
because you know he's not bs in you that
way so he's not perfect but he is young
and he is talented and i'm excited about
cleveland
yeah but but i think what he's doing
this off-season is an extension of the
attitude that he has after a bad
practice he goes into a shell
to protect himself
from himself because he knows if i talk
now i'm going to say something that's
going to make things worse not better i
don't know
maybe i'm i'm going to i'm going to go
back and self-edit myself as it relates
to
whether or not him keeping quiet as a
sign of maturity i think the real sign
of maturity is developing the ability to
speak to the media no matter what your
mindset is no matter whether or not
you're salty you find a way to turn the
light on say what needs to be said do it
in a way that is engaging that is
informative that doesn't create a lot of
unfortunate sound bites that teammates
and coaching staff and pr people have to
clean up for
hours
days maybe weeks after those statements
are made because here's the thing chris
he's not going to be able to move in
silence once it's time to play the games
by rule every player is required to be
available to the media once during the
week
and after each game you have a bad game
you have to be available to media you
have a bad practice on wednesday you
have to be available to the media period
so instead of keeping his mouth shut
i think his better play would be to talk
more and get to the point where he can
juggle however he may be feeling inside
with the importance of not letting them
see it
and not wearing it on his sleeve and not
letting his anger and his frustration
infect the way he speaks and create a
sound bite that's going to create a
problem for him so i change my answer i
think it's a mistake for him to be
moving in silence i think he'd be better
served if he continues to work on
balancing how he feels versus what he
says
well he'll get plenty of chances to talk
once they start training camp and
everything like that
i understand but the point is if he
shuts up for eight months he you need
those reps right i mean you've learned
you've seen what it means for us in this
business the more reps you have the the
better you are you hit your ceiling
whatever your ceiling is whatever
whatever low ceiling we each have on our
broadcasting abilities you get to that
ceiling by doing it over and over and
over again my point is by him sticking
his head in a shell
all off season long and doing
only one so far media availability i
don't know that that prepares him to
handle the frustration that may come
from a bad game against the steelers or
or another miles garrett moment where
remember right after the game it was
mayfield who was calling miles garrett
out and setting a narrative that really
wasn't all that fortunate for miles
garrett so but it was the truth i mean
he said it but sometimes you don't
sometimes in football you don't tell the
truth sometimes you find a way to say
something that answers the question but
you don't wear your heart on your sleeve
now look we prefer it for our purposes
when people are completely candid and
say things that may not be to their best
interest because it gives us stuff to
talk about but the best people with the
media are the ones who find a way to
give answers that are plausible and
credible but not necessarily candid he
was too candid in that moment when he
called out miles garrett well yeah okay
you know and hopefully those are things
he can learn from a little bit i i don't
want him to lose that part of him though
you know be more objective with baker
mayfield in the browns you are too you
are biased for them chris this is me
trying to help you you have a bias for
the browns for odell beckham jr for
baker mayfield you need to learn to be
more objective about this team you're
missing what's right in front of your
face this is a bunch of guys who are
immature they haven't accomplished
anything yet and they need some tough
love not excuse making to get to where
they need to be well yeah okay well get
get a damn coach in there to give them
some tough love teach them how to be
pros that's so that's not their fault
either you know again the culture that
was in cleveland and and really the
culture that we see now or anything
positive is really created by baker
mayfield so i think that tells you a
little bit about what kind of man he is
in a lot of ways again i know he's not
perfect he is young he is learning a
little bit but i just again i think the
the things like him walking off on tony
grossi i again i don't like it i didn't
like it at the time i said that we said
that on air i'm just saying for a young
quarterback in that way it's not the
worst look in the world to me and i
understand what you're saying about reps
but he's trying to be mature in the way
of going okay talk is cheap let me get
my reps on the practice field and i'll
have plenty of time to show people what
i got that way and talk when the season
starts and everything that way as well i
just think this is a group of guys
that's highly motivated they were in a
tough situation last year with a coach
that was in way over their head and
there was a
way over his head and you know there was
a bright light on them and huge
expectations and the one thing i think
baker mayfield made a mistake with more
than anything last year was the over
saturation of baker mayfield too much
talk too many commercials it was like he
had already won two super bowls so i
like that he's kind of gone back into
the cave here and he's gonna start going
just let me get to work and go that way
and it seems like that's all of
cleveland's mindset right now which is i
think refreshing i am biased i
understand that they're easy to like i
wanna like them because i like the way
they handle themselves and they like the
way they play the game
and let's be realistic it's easier to
take a low profile when
no one's interested this year it's not
like he's going to have a bunch of
companies banging on his door to do
commercials this year those are going to
patrick mahomes and lamar jackson not to
baker mayfield because of how he played
last year and one of the reasons his
play was down last year and look let's
not let's not downplay the reality that
freddie kitchens was the wrong guy to
coach the team and you know what that's
a manifestation of baker mayfield having
too much influence as a first year
quarterback because remember that sense
after they they they fired hugh jackson
during the season greg williams became
the interim head coach freddie kitchens
was the offensive coordinator the
offense performed well mayfield
performed well and there was a sense
baker mayfield wanted freddie kitchens
well he got him and it contributed to
the disaster last year for the browns
not a disaster compared to some of their
other disastrous seasons but a disaster
relative to the expectations and i
remember last year chris and we probably
said this is probably in the archives
somewhere they let the expectations get
out of control and no one
harnessed them no one tried to downplay
it no one said we haven't done a damn
thing yet i don't know why everyone is
pegging us to make the playoffs this
team was all in 16 just a couple of
years ago are you all crazy have you
lost your damn minds how do you think
we're a playoff team we have to prove
ourselves and freddie kitchens didn't do
that the organization didn't do it and
baker mayfield didn't do it either now
what they're doing is they're setting
the bar for 2020 and one of the things
baker mayfield addressed yesterday the
reality of jarvis landry's health last
year and otto beckham jr let's hear a
little bit from baker mayfield talking
about the fact that his two top
receivers were far from healthy
throughout 2019 here he is
i think you know them being a little bit
banged up well not a little bit had to
have surgery so uh no it definitely
hindered them physically obviously but
uh the mental part of it the
frustrations that came from that i think
affected it more i mean those guys are
are working extremely hard after their
surgeries for the rehab process and they
look really good they say they feel
really good um
and it it appears that way it just it's
just a different mindset going into it
and i think
like i said i think they went back to
the basics they're ready to you know to
take over and it's their time now they
know that they know
that we only have so many more
opportunities together
and he's right you know those sundays
are
are on in the grand scheme of things 16
a year and they come around quickly and
you better get back on the horse and
figure out how to correct your mistakes
we hear that all the time after games we
have to go back and correct the mistakes
well yeah you don't have many chances
because you make enough mistakes your
season is over you have a a very narrow
window of opportunity once you lose
three four five games you're down to
basically your last chance and they need
to get on top of it with a good start to
the season they struggled last year at
the early stages of the season and it
set a bad tone and and having those guys
healthy is a big part of it the new
coaching staff is a factor in this as
well that's the one of course right
because we say this all the time every
coach wants his own quarterback we don't
know how kevin stefanski truly feels
about baker mayfield will he have him on
any type of a leash this year he's got
case keenum and when kevin stefanski and
keenum were last together in minnesota
they got to the brink of the super bowl
chris so you know if i'm stefanski i'm
looking at what i have in case keenum a
guy who knows my offense and if baker
mayfield slips
uh at what point do i say take a seat
baker you need to you need to watch and
learn from case keenum
well we'll see if that happens i mean
really baker you know case kingdom's a
poor man's baker mayfield that's what he
is or baker mayfield's case keenum just
with more talent that's that's really
how i look at it so there's a lot of
similarities in style i do think baker
mayfield and the browns offense the way
it's built
really will fit the way step kevin
stefanski wants to call a game as an
offensive coordinator i mean we know he
wants to run the ball they got a pretty
good o line there they got a great
running back you know they got tight
ends they got two receivers on the
outside they can they can really steal
the formula that your vikings used last
year and maybe be better at it i mean no
joke uh and you know baker mayfield with
a guy like case keenum behind him i
think it's gonna do him a lot of good
you know it's a little bit of like it's
a little bit of a check yourself before
you wreck yourself okay i got a guy here
behind me where if i have two or three
games where i'm throwing multiple
interceptions and erratic with throws
and things like that yeah this guy's
good enough to come in and and make some
offense happen and put up some points so
i better be on my pc cues i think baker
mayfield realizes that i think he
realizes what a big year it is and you
know also just to what you talked about
with the injuries with jarvis landry and
odell beckham jr hey that affects a team
especially when it's two of your best
players and two of the emotional leaders
of your football team you know think
about it okay yeah odell beckham jarvis
landry they couldn't be as good on the
field but i bet you where they miss and
i've heard some people in cleveland say
this where they missed more than
anything was
they're just infectious uh love of the
game and energy they bring to the you
know it's hard if you're obj or jarvis
you know oh i get a little injury it's
warm ups at practice you're more worried
about oh getting that hip loose and
ready instead if you were 100 healthy
you might be talking crap to the defense
or yelling or just
just increasing the atmosphere and
practice to make everybody go man this
is fun let's get after today and do all
that i think an element was missed there
also with those two guys being injured
so there was a lot of issues in
cleveland last year we crowned them way
too early uh you and me included we were
excited about it i'm every bit as
excited about them again this year in
fact i'm expecting a lot better results
this year it's just they're in a tough
division and it ain't going to be easy
it's always better to have a low bar and
this year the bar is naturally a lot
lower for the browns than it was last
year and that's actually good for baker
mayfield it's good for odell beckham for
jarvis landry for the rest of the team
and for first year head coach kevin
stefanski who who knows that he is
stepping into the revolving door the
question is how many spins will he get
before it spits him out on the other end
because there's a shelf life the moment
you sign a contract with the browns
there's a shelf life but maybe stefanski
who was with the vikings for 14 years he
knows a thing or two about stability and
finding a way to survive through
multiple different coaching staffs and
coordinators maybe stefanski is exactly
what the browns need whoever turns that
team around if that team ever gets to a
super bowl they don't have to win it if
they just get to a super bowl they're
going to name half the town after the
coach yeah they're going to rename all
the neighborhoods after the players i
mean they are starving for a contender
not not even a super bowl winner just
somebody that stumbles into the playoffs
once every two or three years so the
browns fans deserve it that it is
amazing to me that this team has been so
bad for so long and maybe this is the
moment that it finally changes after
last year's false start
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports